what are you doing to stay in shape
there was workouts online I was doing
I'm doing have you heard of tick tock
yeah are you know I'm 75 years old I'm
not allowed to go on I have two teenage
kids that know all about tick tock but
no I do not go on tick tock I always
thought I'd be arrested if I went on
tick tock norm would go off that exists
there's a creepy man on tick tock no I
don't go - tick-tock well you should and
you should do some cheap shots with your
kids because I'm doing them and that's
not the workout that's how I can work
you know you just talk around you
imitate somebody I've been doing high
notes you know you know what I've been
doing I don't know why but before I hit
a high note let's go
back in time every time you say no
seriously if you get to 1993 I'll be
there with sting and I'll go and he'll
give me a look like booth what's your
problem
[Music]
now you brought up ticked-off I want to
bring up something you've done this
thing that's been keeping you busy and
it's a cool idea maybe you could tell us
it's a musical video that you've been
working on yes I just released it um I
don't know if you've heard about I know
you have tiger King Joe lives that Zoo
is not very far from my parents house
okay
have I been because it seems like
something I would have wanted to do and
my dad said we would have never taken
you there it seemed a little shady been
it's shady now you know and but he's
real popular of jail my dad anyway yeah
I'm obsessed and I'm obsessed with Carol
Baskin I'm positive she killed her
husband and fed into the Tigers I'm
positive of it or he's in the septic
tank but it doesn't matter my friend
injured lipless who wrote um the song
that I won the Tony for in Charlie Brown
wrote a Carol Bastion parody it's called
little pieces
[Music]
[Music]
I think it's another way that we're
alike is even in quarantine we'll find
things to do oh yeah find things to do
thank you your crack advances with your
your broom ask I mean I know you come in
I know it really you didn't the Beast
like the lamps in my room have come to
life I'm talking full-on to the mirror
I'm having arguments with myself at 3:00
in the morning
why are you doing this Kristen this is
good it's because it's what you're born
to do